[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is an award this isn't something
that we're going to win
because honestly if we were looking at
winning this we'd have to be taking the
fight to where the enemy is which is
across the border so it's untenable it's
not manageable border patrol is
overwhelmed you know this is something
that's affecting the whole southwest
border but for us in arizona it's having
a huge impact on yuma county the law
enforcement authorities down there the
sheriff's department
an impact to the extent that they they
can't manage it
in a way that they would want to they
use situations like this where there's a
surge of immigration probably legitimate
asylum seekers to absorb the border
patrol and
our customs officials and absorb their
resources
and then start shooting their ill
illegal wares the criminal aliens up
through the border what we do is we work
with the border patrol we work with the
the county sheriff
and we determine where we think the
greatest threat areas are going to be
command border 200. specifically we know
they're in one they'll be somewhere in
the mountain range here
um
they move around obviously they don't
want to be caught a typical day for this
unit the border strike force
for the operation we're currently
running as we deploy
um about 20 hours of the day we spend a
pretty significant amount of time making
traffic stops
so some of the major indicators that we
look are for for travel patterns
for stories that just don't make sense
it's inherently
dangerous because the people that we
deal with
um
do not want to be caught we're not
seeing the the marijuana we're not we're
not seeing those types of
drugs we're seeing methamphetamine and
fentanyl primarily coming across the
border here in arizona right now we are
seeing a serious uptick in the
at very least possession of weapons
by people that are involved in the
cartel activities and the smuggling
activities in the areas we operate in
it's for a couple reasons number one
it's because of the increase in
value and potency of the drugs that are
coming across
but it's also that the cartels are in a
kind of a constant state of war with
each other and there are what we call
rip crews or crews that will come and
try to rip off both humans
and drugs from from these coyotes or
from um
these
smugglers that are bringing the drugs in
so
it's become a much more violent game
in
in mexico the cartels run their drug and
their human smuggling operations very
much like a business and it is it's part
of doing business to have law
enforcement take a load a load of dope
or a you know a load of of uh people
they they kind of factor that into their
cost of doing business in one seizure we
took down 30 pounds of fentanyl
okay so that's 30 pounds that's
roughly 5 000 pills a pound
two milligrams in one pill is enough to
be fatal the fact of the matter is is
that it is so profitable and it is there
is such an appetite for illicit drugs
here in the united states as well as for
for uh
cheap labor or sex trafficking and it's
it's something that
we know that it gets through i'd love
the policy the makers to really
understand
um
the aspects of what's going on
um and the unintended consequences of
the policies that are made when you talk
about how do we keep our morale up it's
because we know that every single load
we get every single gram every single
ounce every single pound
of these drugs that we take off that we
stop
stops them from getting into the hands
of one of our kids
and we know that we we have saved a life
you